we have a voicemail number two one nine
two david p this is a voicemail from
arguably the biggest football fan and
david pakman show audience history Grady
who was was interested in in Pat's
comments about fanny packs last week
hey David is grading I hope you had a
fantastic Lamoille Day weekend but this
message is for fanny pack pack no fanny
pack Pat I'm for Sarah Sarah Pat Pat you
have totally earned your place on a show
in my heart you are don't you are no you
are not the listen Lewis will always be
Lois but you have earned your place in
my opinion I just want to say great job
you dummies it was a fantastic show and
I hope you have a choreo summer and you
know just live your life uh ciao ciao
Grady clearly has more time on his hands
now that the Cowboys are in the
offseason could you have predicted that
your pro fanny pack statements could
have had such an impact on the audience
that I could have predicted but I had
thought that Grady had my approval all
along uh I had heard you know I didn't
realize it took this long well um listen
sometimes there are challenges in life
okay and sometimes we overcome them and
clearly that has happened as far as
Grady is concern and I can keep a list
of those challenges in my fanny pack so
I know when to deal with them and on our
reddit is covered in fanny pack related
memes now and anyway check that out on
the bonus show today golfer Tiger Woods
arrested on DUI charges in Jupiter
Florida more problems at Chipotle and
I'll tell some stories from Montreal of
that on the bonus show david pakman.com
slash membership to sign up and get
instant access